أردت حقًا أن تشعر وكأنك كنت
حرفياً في مجموعة إذا نظرت إلى معظم
هذه المجموعات ، فإن الجدران لا تسير على طول
الطريق ، إنها خيالية إنها ليست حقيقية ،
إنها تجربة فريدة من نوعها
لمطوري العقارات في سينسيناتي ، أوتو
وبريندا بوم يريدون ذلك  جعل
موضوع الأصدقاء هذا ، Airbnb و Seinfeld Theme ، Airbnb
و Pleasant Ridge
Neighborhood في سينسيناتي ، نسختين طبق الأصل من
كلاسيكيات التلفزيون المليئة
بالتذكارات ، الباب في سينفيلد
المدخل وسينفيلد أرادوا
أن يكون هذا مثاليًا لأنك  شاهد
كرامر يأتي من هذا الباب عدة
مرات وستكون هناك بعض
ألعاب الطاولة وهناك حلقة مع
اللمعان في الفريزر لذلك لدينا
اللمعان في الفريزر ،
مفهوم القنبلة لهذه الأجنحة المسرحية الهزلية المكونة من غرفة نوم واحدة
والحمام الواحد جاءت في
الارتفاع  من الوباء بسبب
حب الزوجين للعروض ومشاهدتها
لساعات مع أطفالهم في
الحجر الصحي ، وضعوا خطتهم موضع
التنفيذ في أكتوبر ، اعتقدت أنك تعلم أنه
قد يكون من الممتع فعلاً أن تحب الذهاب لمشاهدة
مجموعة ثم ماذا سيكون
سيكون من الرائع الجلوس
في مجموعة حتى تكون قادرًا على الإعجاب بالعيش في
المجموعة والعثور على جميع صور المفروشات
والمزيد لمطابقة جاء مع
تحدياته الفريدة الخاصة به لأكثر من ثلاثة أشهر
من العمل الذي أخذهم إلى سبعة
مختلفة  تنص على استكشاف متاجر التوفير متاجر
التحف Facebook Marketplace و
Craigslist للغرامات ، إنها مجموعة صغيرة ، إنها
غرفة صغيرة نتعامل معها في
نهاية اليوم ، لا يزال لديك
قدر محدود من اللقطات المربعة ، لذا
ربما كان هذا هو التحدي الأكبر عندما
يقولون  المنتج النهائي يستحق العناء ويريدون أن
يشاركه معجبو التلفزيون في
كل مكان مع
أحبائهم لسنوات قادمة ، أريدهم أن
يأتوا إلى هنا ويشاهدون الأصدقاء
ويقضون وقتًا مع أصدقائك ، أريد أن يشعر
الناس بهذا الحنين إلى
الماضي.  عندما أتذكر ذلك أو أتذكره أو كنت
أفعل ذلك في ذلك الوقت ، لذا فهو يشبه
الشعور وأعتقد أنه سيكون فريدًا
لكل شخص ولكن في جوهره مجرد نوع من
إعادتك إلى الزمان والمكان